good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast i know what you're
thinking claudia you said there was no
episode well i lied because i'm a big
liar and i'm joined by one of my besties
a toast regular at this point mr brian
kelly aka the points guy hey brian how
you doing thanks for having me on this
what could be kind of like a solemn day
yeah so not to bring the mood down but
there's a lot we're gonna get through
today yeah so let's talk about why we're
here so
um we had no episode scheduled for today
but you and i have been meaning to make
this episode together um just to talk
about
your intervention after my intervention
yeah just to talk a little bit about
what's been going on with you and um
before we dive in i know that you you've
been like holding like a secret not a
secret because that makes it sound bad
but like you know um
there's a part of yourself you haven't
revealed yeah but you might also want to
give the trigger warning trigger warning
um brian and i are about to be
incredibly annoying and dramatic um but
that's what we do here at the morning to
us we love we love a moment you know
today is the episode of secrets i've got
some secrets to share today that should
be our title today episode of secrets
that's why her hair is so big it's full
of secrets
so tell me a little bit about what the
last couple of before we dive in tell me
a little bit about what the last couple
of months have been like for you
you know like once the not like other
girls tour wrapped in may it was it was
tough on him
yeah like
because
being on tour with all the girls
like camaraderie family community yeah
like that hetero energy i really
connected with
that much i've always known about you
know the girls like
tour like just getting that validation
and when it just
dropped one day
i missed the girls you know you missed
the girls and by the way the girls have
missed too so i'm sure everyone is
thrilled that you're on today's episode
but um i have a big secret for them
that you're you're kind of like you know
i think it's time you're sharing your
truth
i'm gay
claudia we're going to pretend to be
wait we actually kidding there's other
big news that i want to share so brian
first of all thank you for giving the
toasty exclusive on what you actually
have to share because it's wonderful
amazing amazing news and the toasters i
mean i'm so happy for you the toasters
are going to be so happy when they hear
what's been going on with you um so now
i think let's really share what's and by
the way not to make everything about me
but i've obviously known about what yes
but so actually and there's claudia
there's a secret you don't know
okay so let's say okay let's get into
the big secret i am gonna be a dad yes
brian is pregnant with a baby well
you're not pregnant brian is has a baby
on the way
bun in the oven coming very soon too we
are full third trimester you've been so
like low-key about it um
the fact that like when this episode
hits like babies will be here like
imminently soon yes uh
yeah it's always been a dream of mine um
and i think when the pandemic hit you
know i had broken up with my ex-fiance
you know tpg's business kind of like you
know took a pause i'm home i'm in
pennsylvania i'm surrounded by family my
nieces my nephews and i've always known
i wanted to be a dad and at that point i
was 37 and i just remember thinking like
i want to be a young-ish dad right what
about my first kid in my 30s and you
know being gay and doing ivf
the whole process takes a long time so
it was you know the fall of 2020 i
actually started to get you know serious
about it and it's been a you know pretty
amazing i'm very lucky it'll basically
be two years from the day i started
to having
my son
oh yeah it's a boy it's a boy it's a boy
um and i want to ask you all about like
the process but i'm curious if at all
because i've we've been on like several
trips together um since we've known that
you're pregnant and that your circus
pregnant sorry
and i find people's reaction to it very
mixed because they're like
oh are you married or and you're doing
it by yourself like and i love and i'm
curious if one it ever crossed your mind
to wait until you found the right person
and two
what like what was it about the idea of
doing it on your own that made you want
to do it even more because i know yeah
i think
uh
you know certainly waiting you know
doing it and i and you know to be honest
i am still friends with my ex
but i think i was rushing into that i
proposed after nine years
i was like rushing because in my head i
have to check all these boxes right i
can't have my kid until i'm married and
oh i probably rush that relationship way
too quickly and then of course then the
pandemic hit and then i'm like i'm not
even dating in 2020. like dating in 2020
was psychotic psychotic it's psychotic
normally
let alone a pandemic so i'm like there's
no way i'm gonna have a you know i'm
living in pennsylvania loving life on
the farm you know i don't have the farm
then but
um so i was like you know there's no way
that i would have a kid in my 30s if i
had waited until after the pandemic yeah
you have a time meeting and then also i
mean just looking i mean my parents are
still together after
almost 40 over 45 years wow
but so many families aren't and i just
may call me selfish but i'm like i just
i'm already so attached to my son i'm
like i will never split him like you
know and so a part of me is like i have
the financial resources i have an
amazing family
and i'm gonna have help
lots of help and i'm not gonna you know
so why not do it on my own no and i
actually think
being a single gay dad well like
attract me to the right person that i
want to be with i completely agree with
that like i think
you entering this new era of your life
very you know domesticated almost that's
the type of energy you're going to start
to attract
and i love that as like a barometer for
who you bring like is this person good
enough to meet my son yeah and a lot of
gay single friends who have done it um
my one friend had twins they're nine
years old amazing happy obviously andy
cohen
and seeing anderson cooper
and their modern families and just happy
like you
i think you know and i work with a lot
of kids in charities like kids need love
you know that's it and i'm gonna give my
kid and potentially kids lots and lots
of love no your kid is well actually
there's one other secret that you don't
know about oh okay so i've been showing
claudia the child's name is claudia
claude
claude kelly that's cute no actually so
i've been showing claudia the uh
pictures of an egg donor that it's not
the real egg donor i'm the egg donor no
you want are you ready you harvest what
margot is done
no i'm serious that wouldn't be fair
honestly like after we we kind of like
hooked up in vegas right i remember yeah
that's how i knew you were straight
by the way if what would you do then i
would literally that would make you my
well nothing it would make you my
it would make you my nephew's wait
biological dad no
but if margot was your egg donor that
child would be like gorgeous and tall
like that's almost like not and savvy
i'm just so proud of margot she's such a
boss she's killing it she's my baby yeah
wait i have so many questions for you
and i know a lot of the process but
so you make this decision and i love the
decision like why wait for life to start
you have all the means you have so much
love to give you a huge family there's
literally no reason not to do it
where does one start after that as a
single game i actually i started my
doctor in new york was gay and had kids
so he recommended me to a surrogacy kind
of consultant it was a woman in
minnesota she had like the small
surrogacy practice in the whole process
of ivf
um you know getting eggs is relatively
easy
um
and getting an ivf clinic to make
embryos with your sperm and an egg like
that process is not that hard it's like
you get the egg you know as long as your
sperm is healthy or eggs healthy like
it's pretty you have strong swimmers
luckily so it's really funny when you
donate or you you give your sperm they
actually put it through like a a race
course wow so like your your swimmers
have to go boop boop boop boop boop like
and only the strongest right they use
for the insemination
so you get your strongest swimmers and
then
i decided to you can buy frozen eggs
from clinics i was recommended i my egg
donor i chose the egg donor and then she
did a whole she cycled and i got all of
her eggs from one month so you have a
bunch of options so i had a ton of eggs
and then
in the lab
you know they
inseminate them all
and i chose to do genetic testing which
allows you and the clinic that i used in
sandy san diego fertility clinic they're
amazing
uh i'll just shout out dr donishmann is
like top in the industry he's so amazing
but anyway so once you have all the
embryos they put them through testing so
you can actually see they rank all of
the eggs and you know
more than half of the embryos were like
not great quality got it so if you do
this testing you can actually rank and
use the strongest
embryo that has the highest chance of
you know surviving right um so i was
very lucky the first time that i
transferred it took um wow and that's by
the way that happens to nobody like it
was very
but and uh but the biggest like pain
point is surrogacy so apparently during
2020 everyone decided oh you know i can
work remotely
now is the time to have kids yeah
so there are very long like weight loss
weightless for surrogates and of course
me you know coming from my airline elite
status i'm like where's the priority
line like
where can i upgrade and jump the list
but when it comes to human life you know
like they're very and which is amazing
as it should be um
so
but luckily there uh is an lgbt
focused smaller agency
that when at one point i had talked
about wanting to have kids and they
reached out to me they were tpg fans
elevate baby is their name um
awesome awesome people um
kyle dean massey is the founder he's
like an actor
turned now surrogacy um
company owner him and his husband
actually just had a baby taylor fry
so anyway they're really good but they
had reached out to me and said if you're
looking
and connected they were like we have the
perfect surrogate so
um i think so many people told me like
and i i remember talking about it in the
press years ago like that i wanted to
have a baby people are like don't jinx
yourself you know there's a lot of
superstitions of course but the because
i talked about it in an article they
reached right and i'm having a baby
today because i was open about the
process yeah of course i know
it's different for everyone and some
people you know certainly it's very
private and i respect everyone's
decision but sometimes like putting it
into the universe
like can can pay off so
i got matched with this amazing
surrogate who you've had she's so i mean
the fact that she is carrying your giant
child she's tiny like it is shocking i
actually felt guilty wait they told you
you couldn't do twins yeah they were
like
so i didn't think she would actually be
allowed to be my surrogate because she
was so small yeah um but this is her you
know she's had kids before
my ivf doctor was like no no it doesn't
work like that like she'll be fine
so um but this is definitely uh she's
like this baby is huge it's huge and by
the way the best part and i feel like
i've really been around for so much of
the process but like unintentionally we
didn't even know we were out to dinner
in new hope with your parents
when she you had done the process of
incent you flew out to san diego to
inseminate right yeah so the embryo
transfer so you create these 10-day old
embryos and then they freeze them
so i
um and you the cool thing is if you want
they'll actually tell you the sex of the
baby
and um did you choose to have a boy i
did choose to have a boy i i was torn
because i it really doesn't matter it
doesn't but like
three of my really close friends all had
baby boys in the last year and just a
part of me maybe that is that the
patriarchy no i think no i was just like
now that i have this like farm and all
the other boys i know i just felt like
it's a boys club yeah i know maybe
that's like problematic no it's like
what my gut said and at the end of the
day when it comes to you have to family
planning you can do whatever you want
but i just think it's amazing whether
you're gay or having fertility issues
like there is so much science now that
can like dramatically i have a lot of my
you know lesbian friends who just had a
baby via ivf like the science is kind of
crazy it's amazing by the way like how
you were able to watch that picture of
you literally with your mask on holding
that picture with tears in your eyes
like is literally the cutest whole
process when i transferred the embryo i
was in the doctor's office you see your
frozen embryo this 10 day old
and it's like defrosting you have to
verify that it's yours obviously all
these controls and then the you know the
doctor and you know inserts it and i you
know saw that little embryo land on like
the uterine wall or endometrium wall or
i'm still like not great that's
something that you know when you get
pregnant the conventional way
you can't no my mom said to me she's
like how cool is that that you literally
have known your son since the time that
he was like creative yeah instant crazy
and i started bawling that day because i
instantly knew i knew i was like
pregnant that day yeah it was
and then when she called you like a week
or two later like she officially had
taken the test yeah
she didn't she yeah my surrogate is like
she's very in tune with her body and she
was like you know i didn't feel
she was like i hate you know she was
like i don't want to get your hopes up
and of course you know the odds are you
know
never in your favor but then um
yeah she was like do you want me to take
a pregnancy test and i'm like
technically i think she's supposed to
wait another week yeah but she knew but
she's like you know of course pregnancy
test isn't perfect and then i was out to
dinner with you and that was so much fun
holy moly here we go so that was
like january yeah that's so crazy so now
everyone's like are you nervous i'm like
no i'm not i mean i know my life's gonna
change but i've jumped through so many
hoops to get here excited you're ready
like it's been a long time coming yes so
now here's what i'm focused on first of
all the baby shower which i am actively
planning with a few people when i tell
you like you're not [ __ ] ready for
what is gonna go down like
it is gonna be so twisted
it's gonna be like a last hurrah for you
it's like it's not like other babies
this is actually i've like this is
so normally i'm the one to plan events
travel you could call me a control freak
just a little and like i did feel weird
my mom i was like i don't want to do a
registry you know i feel you have to but
my mom was like no you idiot like no
we're doing a registry people want to
get you gifts it's okay to accept gifts
it's not about being able to afford it's
about allowing people to and so many
people have been like the gifts that i
got at my baby shower like save me and
like you don't even know what the hell
i'm doing so yes please i will take the
help like i've helped everyone plan
trips so yeah right parents out there
who are like no this is what you need
yes i'm not gonna be like no no because
no end like you need so much [ __ ]
crap like you don't even realize how
every little thing and all these things
you accumulate you're gonna need so
you're very nice to not want to do it
but i was like you're kidding me my mom
wouldn't let me she's like and by the
way what did i get brian i tried to go
nice you know one of the more expensive
things on the registry this [ __ ]
chair jackie sends me because jackie has
the chair it's like a motorized chair
jackie sends me a message the next day
huge recall of this chair it was very
dangerous i'm like brian return the
chair claudia's already trying to kill
me i'm coming yeah because literally
he's taking too much time away from me
now i want to know what kind of dad
you're going to be like did you grow up
in a strict household i did well strict
for sure my parents i grew up very
respectful
i i call myself like the last
wave of like
my parents were not helicopter parents
like i grew up in my neighborhood i have
two older brothers and younger sister
like we would leave the house in the
summer at like 8 a.m on our bikes go to
the pond like as long as you're home by
five for dinner and then you go out and
come like my parents were like do
whatever you want and i like that
because i think my parents but they also
like ran a strict household yeah i
didn't curse
my parents didn't hit me but like they
would you wouldn't get punished when you
said you're a god like my mom could snap
her fingers
she'd be on like a corded phone in the
kitchen this is the 90s she would like
look at me and snap and i'd be like you
know i'm sorry yeah i don't think i'm
gonna be that strict um no but i do
think it's important to fear your
parents a little bit not in like an
actually scary way but in a way where
you respect them and you respect
authority i do believe
like your child you know
he will be a part of my life we're going
to travel like
he will travel from a young age and i
know that's going to be different and i
know there are things i'm going to say
today that like are the parents out
there who are listening yeah we all
but you know i want to show him the
world like i actually now am like
you know
i didn't i mean i traveled domestically
growing up but like he's gonna i want
him to really see the world and i think
it'll change the way i travel of course
um and the way you see the world yeah
and you know we've got a long time
before he goes to school so
you know spending some time abroad and
um i don't know but i also want to wait
to see what he likes i think i've been
reading a lot on like parenting and
it's like i want to and you know the
things that he naturally likes i want to
encourage of course and so what um what
like things have you been reading
websites books like have you been
leaning on to kind of prepare yourself
well the biggest thing is so my friend
is a doula and she
like i'm just in the mode now of like
okay
you know like learning about the
skin-to-skin like i want to be in that
room instantly no one touches my son no
one weighs him he will go instantly on
my chest you know if possible right like
um
and just understanding you know the
sleep training
the formula you know which european
formula is the best like
dutch goat milk versus
um
so so uh so that i'm like in that mode
i'm like i mean i always read articles
on parenting and
um
but yeah i think and mostly just talking
to fellow parents yeah a lot of my
friends have had kids um and most of my
you know all the kids you know in my
life are really amazing
well-adjusted kids for the most part so
i don't know um so in this moment like
what do you feel you feel peace you feel
anxiety you feel excitement i feel
excitement i feel
um
yeah i feel like his due date
i just have this sense that he's going
to come early my surrogate feels that
he's so it's like
uh and i have to travel so there's just
like a little bit of like i'm just ready
for it to happen but
this isn't like nature i can't like
can't rush it you can't schedule it i
want him to be on his time you know so
but i'm excited i'm also excited to take
time off work i've actually never
taken an extended amount of time off
work even when i travel i'm always sort
of working you know first not that i'm
complaining about my gig
but like to really unplug from work
for
a while and
yeah and just spend time in the fall
with the new baby on my farm it's gonna
be
beyond i'm so so so excited and you have
a name picked out we're obviously not
gonna share it have a name that i've
just always loved it's a strong name and
you know my everyone i tell is like oh
that's good yeah it's kelly kelly kelly
kelly that's cute by the way yeah and
did you fact when you were thinking of
names you factored in your last name is
really unique because it's um a first
name and a last name so it makes like it
can be really punchy yeah i think a lot
of your success has to do with your name
honestly brian kelly like that's it
christina brianna christina vanner pump
joaquilla armstrong leaks kelly
wacheele
um
and so when you're thinking about like
names jackie was really like you really
don't know how hard it is until you have
to name a full human being so you had
this name i know you had it for a while
even before i had the name for as long
as i can remember and it just like it
stands the test of time i think i like
this name when i was 16. yeah it's like
it's strong and iconic so
uh i feel very strong about it plus his
middle name will be a family name that
like uh oh yeah it's just it's got a
you know i feel i feel very strongly
about even though jackie had suggested a
name that almost
took off
your name jackie's good with names this
one
well so your name is brian kelly and so
is your dad he's senior so but i'm not
junior because we have different middle
names so
to have a third brian so jackie
recommended or she her suggestion was
we'll call him trip right which
obviously because he's the third
but you're the points guys
so we thought about it for like double
on tone yeah because it has multiple
meanings but eventually the name you had
was better and like tripp kelly that i
mean that would be a really good name
jackie
i mean he's so good he sounds like a
douche like yeah he's southern a little
southern pops his collar you know but i
like it yeah he's an essay yeah like
he's a frat guy yeah he loves beer kegs
dance wait um so
i'm not religious i'm not doing god
mothers and god parents what
like but you're obviously gonna be
special to him so what should we auntie
claudia yeah i mean i'll have to think
like i'll have to see how my
relationship with him blossoms what are
you gonna do if he's straight
set him up with margo
but literally i was just saying this to
jackie for some reason my association
with margo is so young when we're out to
dinner and i see a 15 year old i'm like
oh my good boy for margot even though
like margo's 25 now i just like keep of
course can you always like on text
chains margot she doesn't make time for
us anymore she doesn't
she's too busy at high school
no if your son is straight um i will of
course accept him as he is and i will
find a nice jewish girl for him perfect
or even if he's gay i'll find a nice
jewish boy for him but um
when he becomes a certain age i will not
stop setting him up he's probably gonna
hate me yeah i mean if he's straight
he'll hate me if he's gay he'll love me
sickening the house sick
we'll send we'll sing janet and celine
together
and that's another where does janet fit
into all this janet pasta is gonna come
out for the delivery wow
um
and yeah he's excited he like he's gonna
make literally homemade formula
yeah well we tried to put him through a
lactation course but unfortunately it
didn't take it didn't work it was tough
on us
and by the way for people pasta is my
best friend sister
and honestly this is gonna really change
his life too no but it's like we're
doing this together i know it's like
nice the pasta's fans are called the
noodles i love them
we've got the toasters the noodlers
and you wouldn't um by the way just to
switch gears pasta like we were tubing
and pasta had fans on the delaware river
okay that's like pasta we went to a
party later that night in bucks county
pasta fazzullo i mean his content is
possible is about to like just blow up
take over mario batali watch out
cooking with babs watch out watch out i
love her olivia loves her
oh my god okay so you feel like how do
you well this episode comes out tomorrow
but still like now that everyone knows
you are going to get i feel like so feel
i mean to all the new moms and dads out
there feel free to dm me your tips i am
open to all of you product
recommendations yeah i love this i've
already got the duna the duna travel
jackie is obsessed with the dude
pro
i've got my
nestig wave crib oh good like it's a
crib that turned into a bed that turns
into like fabulous uh the nursery theme
is like we'll have to wait and see on my
instagram oh i don't even know what that
is
i just kind of finalized the concept i
had a lot of different ideas but um
we're just gonna do like a safari type
theme you're gonna oh by the way that's
amazing you're gonna be such a good dad
like this is the role you were born to
play i'm so happy for you i'm happy for
me like because first of all i was able
to keep the secret for well over two
years good on me because i'm i told
people jackie was pregnant and i was
like
i told you on the river it was like
literally so easy i'm like and i kept
the secrets so [ __ ] good and i did
elude um like two weeks ago on the toast
that like i have a really big event
coming up it was your
baby shower
um and i was like you guys are going to
do you know what you're going to wear
yet no i need to get do you have to wear
do i have to wear blue no because that's
like i think it's just like you know oh
my god look at me projecting my
heteronormativity on you i'm so sorry
wait do you remember that time i came
out on your toes yeah no um no it's the
dumbest thing we've ever done we just
wanted to be funny i think we're
hilarious like we're funny
um you're gonna be i would just say like
i when i was a kid in the 90s like i
knew i was gay and i would go to bed and
be like if i could take a pill to be
straight because i want to have kids and
i never thought i'd be able to have kids
oh yeah so like to all the
the gay boys out there or girls and
people you know battling infertility
just like
everything happens the way it's meant to
happen you might have chills i love that
it's so full circle you're literally
like doing what you were put on this
earth to do you know to make a mini you
god you can terrorize this earth for the
next 50 years apparently he's like kick
like a lot of the things like my
surrogate sent me pic like videos of him
just ramming through her
apparently he's very active he's ready
he's a party boy he wow that's someone
like his father
well the toasters are so happy for you i
know they're going to freak out i love
you so much mazel tov
and make sure to be following brian
kelly on instagram like for all the dad
updates all your tips
send fellow um single gay dads his way
as well yeah i think that's important to
remember
thank you guys for listening enjoy this
episode enjoy your weekend have an
amazing weekend and jackie and i will be
back for regular episodes on monday i
love you all tickets available at girl
with no job.com tour bye